big big announcement
Roney is back got new women yes
[Applause]
can you run me through who these women
are and what we're gonna get out of them
and why they were the fit to take the
show into this next chapter we were
looking for a group of friends who were
actually uh connected and who are
vibrant living Eve all over New York
City uh with interesting jobs and
interesting relationships and we found
them with this group we've got women in
our group is Brooklyn Tribeca the East
Side Chelsea the West Village so they're
all over town they're actually friends
they have real jobs
um that are uh you know we've got a
fashion PR person we've got a Somali
supermodel we've got uh Jenna Lions who
is known I mean she revitalized the
J.Crew brand she she is speaks for
herself uh we've got a Instagram
influencer
Aaron Jessel Brynn Sai and Jenna it is
so beautiful to see you holding apples
you look so beautiful so there's all
different types and I'm really excited
they're energy and excitement and humor
uh it's gonna be a whole new Roni
Dorinda crashed your ask Andy panel
today not since joseon confronted me on
the air about why she was fired have I
been uh confronted like that by a
housewife I loved it and so listen it's
an interesting segue because yes we were
waiting to lock the cast of the new Roni
before we really got into who's going to
be on Legacy
we now Monday we're gonna start getting
into that now or press and play on
Monday we were pressing we're slowly
pressing play on Monday we're taking out
the pen and paper on Monday
foreign